they look called stop dealing tick tock
videos with groups of people the pool
Nick viola seemingly slams Hannah Brown
and Tyler Cameron's quarantine crew are
you turned someone specifically oh you
know just pointing it out while on
Claudia
oshri AKA a girl with no jobs Instagram
live on Wednesday the 39 year old
reality star got heated about people
taking social distancing seriously
could he be referring to this although
Nick doesn't get specific
it seems the former bachelor is directly
referencing his fellow bachelor nation
alums okay I'm bored in the house and
I'm in the house bored bored in a house
and I'm in the house boy Nick's concern
is for good reason as the pair has been
flaunting at their vacation style
quarantine by the pool in South Florida
with their pals even creating a nickname
and social media account for their squad
called the quarantine crew while the
rest of America is practicing social
distancing amid the corona virus
pandemic he's still a dancer so they
mess around and danci hoedown seemingly
back on couple has been spending plenty
of time together it's been you know
life-changing earlier this week the 27
year old model and the former
bachelorette were spotted on the beach
together after Tyler picked up Hannah
from the Palm Beach Airport and they've
been hanging out ever since she's an
amazing girl like there's there's you
know I gave it my all and she's she's
incredible but no word on whether
they're officially back on I'm trying to
you know date privately
[Music]